i want to talk about something uh that's
a sore spot for me which is your husband
um you married this guy without ever
consulting me and
as someone who used to you know hang out
at my set illegally
at night i think the least you could
have done is talk to me and cleared
this marriage but you didn't you plowed
ahead without me
how do you pronounce his name because
his name is like it's spelled
g-i-j-s which looks like
gig doesn't make sense yeah where is he
from first of all
so he's from the netherlands which is
what
we call holland and i'm just like pick a
name there's too many names but everyone
always thinks
holland is denmark and i'm like is it
isn't it who knows i'm not jack gusto
but i had to learn how to say his name
because we're
married and i just want to call him bo
but everybo i call everybody boo so his
name is pronounced
nice and if you're going to go for it
it's okay is that true
it's is it you're not kidding that's
what it's really his name is supposed to
be
yes because guys i don't know if you
ever argued with someone named
guys it's hard okay but the dutch names
are
beautiful and exotic and old world
because
kaiser's best friend is named thais guys
had a
cat named whose i was like you better
stop the names are crazy
my mother-in-law her name is hanukkah is
johanna but you legally shorten it to
hanukkah in holland and i'm like like
the holiday and she's like it's nothing
like the holiday
girl kwanzaa listen conan
hanukkah your mother-in-law's name is
hanukkah
yes hanukkah mother of heiss
yes wow but my brother-in-law his name
is kun and it's real hard introducing
him to my black friends in america
i would imagine i'm just gonna sing yeah
that's
unfortunate yeah the names are
interesting yeah yeah you probably
you shouldn't bring that guy around just
leave him leave him in the netherlands
you know what was it like growing
up with a name like conan though what
was your nickname uh
i didn't have a nickname no one thought
of a nickname for me i was just conan
and it was okay before
19 you know in the early 1980s and then
right around the time
that i got into that i was in high
school or leaving high school
the conan the barbarian movie came out
and was huge
and then my life became a living hell
because yeah because everybody was like
you know what's your name and i'd say
conan they'd be like where's your sword
that was my father uh
yeah so it was it was rough but that's
where i learned to fight and that's why
i'm such a good fighter now why i have
such
big muscles yeah i see them from here i
feel
scared that's nice that your dad gave
you a cool name though my dad just named
me after him his name is michelle muto
i'm michelle pitel
i think it's just because he's bad with
names wow yeah he just he
he phoned it in is what you're saying
yes now
your husband where is he from in holland
is he from
like is he from amsterdam where is he
from no
i wish he was because amsterdam was so
cool it's gorgeous there
it's i love it um he is from the
outskirts of amsterdam it's two hours
south it's called eindhoven
and um you know it's cute it's all right
it's clean
it's not very what you would say diverse
you know a lot of people look
related and even the farms i'm like
where's the black sheep i don't see it
but you know i don't mind going people
are nice they make eye contact
um the food is good can i ask how they
react to you
i'm imagining this is like a completely
white culture
and super white and you show up
how do they react you know i've gotten
it all honey i've gotten
um plus-sized beyonce i've gotten
that's what they call you plus-sized
beyonce they say it with their face
they say with their face okay i've
gotten like meghan markle let herself go
i've got the new thing with kids though
they think i look like nicole buyer from
nailed it and which is crazy because
we're friends and also look nothing
alike
so you know they want me to say nailed
it a lot that's quite interesting
you know as of late it's a lot of raven
simone and i'm like that's not
raven so take it back but yeah
i mean i just wish people would do the
research they just did a little research
look um what uh
before you got married what kind of guy
did you attract normally or what kind of
guy were you attracted to
oh my goodness you know the kind of guy
that i was attracted to was still like
when people ask me what kind of person i
want to work with what celebrities i
want to work with i'm just like anyone
who hasn't me
to someone really is my type right
there's three left
so you gotta move fast call me out
okay she's an award winner but um
it's so crazy because i you know a lot
of my single friends are like i want
what you have and i'm like
that's cute um you know they have these
unrealistic types yeah you know like
tall and handsome i'm just like don't
skip out on the short dudes okay because
they reach like what they're supposed to
but i love that i'm laughing at myself
you can tell that i have been with
two-year-olds
for so long this is so nice even more
perfume for this
no one is going to smell it but it's so
crazy because
the the type that i would attract was
definitely government workers government
workers
love me like you want to go to the post
office with me during christmas
because they'll be like you get over
here not the club not the lie at the
club the like the post office
that's where at so they open up when you
go to the
the post office or any place where
there's government workers they lift the
velvet rope and you go right on through
yes yes like at the red carpet yes the
bottle service
it's amazing i don't know why yeah i'm
trying to figure out what that's i'm
trying to figure out what that's all
about but you just seem to really
that's your that's your core demo
people yeah it is and people in prison
hi i love you so much i get people in
prisons too
yes look this is gonna be a great
episode guys in prison
love me they just do we've never figured
it out
actually we did once i won't get into it
but i'm very popular
okay you're like a hilarious johnny cash
[Laughter]
i don't think that's it